Mariah Carey was his first passenger I
was like this will work
I was like this is bulletproof you and
then Mariah Carey came out of the house
to get in the car and said to me listen
I'm not going to sing today see me in
the cover like come on was there a
moment when you realized this is working
you know it went from kind of outgoing
calls to try and get people to do the
show to Michelle Obama you know her team
calling the office direct to say the
first lady would really like to do a
carpool karaoke and then you're like
okay I guess it's working you know
Mariah Carey was his first passenger I
was like this will work
I was like this is bulletproof and then
Mariah Carey came out of the house
to get in the car and said to me listen
I'm not going to sing today see me in
the cover like come on was there a
moment when you realized